oh hey excuse me um are you a crypto
exchange yep that's correct you can call
me SPF I'm a philanthropist and FDX is
the third largest crypto exchange
trusted by the one and only Tom Brady
yeah well I got eight billion dollars
here and I just need to put it somewhere
safe where I can trade uh can you do
that for me of course my goal my one
goal is to do right by customers
I'm a philanthropist okay well um this
eight billion dollars is really
important to me I understand we're 100
legit just look at all these appliances
endorsing us
oh my God that is legit it is really
important that marketplaces act in a
responsible manner here it's not about
how much money we make but it's about
the impact we can make to change the
world I mean I I believe everything we
do is for the greater good of the
ecosystem and for the end user
oh did I tell you I was a philanthropist
yeah yeah I just want to make sure that
you understand how vital it is for me to
have access to these funds
um
all right here we go thank you okay so
we're gonna deposit here and know that
we hold our customer assets one to one
so you have nothing to worry oh
sorry I slipped are you all right yeah
I'm fine I just slipped you still have
my money right oh yes of course
um yeah here it is
huh
um yeah it looks a little bit different
but I I guess that's fine
um anyways thanks I'm gonna head out
uh actually can I have my money back
oh yeah no problem just give me a minute
oh
um here we go
where's the rest of it
now I think after what happened it's
even more important now than ever to
self-store your crypto with
non-custodial wallets which is why this
video is sponsored by one inch wallet
now this wallet is actually the most
friendly D5 wallet I've ever used you
can store and transfer all your crypto
assets on all of these chains like
ethereum BNB chain polygon but most
importantly it's a decentralized mobile
app meaning you own your own keys so
unlike centralized exchanges your crypto
assets aren't managed by someone else if
you want to interact with a
decentralized app you can use wallet
connect for example if I want to connect
to Open Seas all I need to do is Click
wallet connect and then scan this QR
code
there you go now my wallet's connected
so if you need to store your crypto
somewhere safe and also easy to use
check out one inch wallet on the app
store or on Android all right
took me a while to find you [ __ ] get
away you SEC relax I'm not the SEC
I'm assembling the team
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you